I'm sitting here with Nick Artman.
He's one of our
front-end web developers.
Thanks for sitting with me.
>> Absolutely.
>> So,
tell me a little bit about refactoring.
What's one way that
you might go about it?
>> So, refactoring is the process by
which you take a piece of code and make
it more readable and more maintainable
without changing its functionality.
So that means, you might want to
break up large functions,
or complicated functions without
changing the way that they're
accessed by the outside world or the
other components of your application.
>> Got it.
So basically you're taking
the organization, which we'll say in
this case is already all right, and
you're taking the big unmaintainable or
difficult to understand functions and
you're breaking them up.
But it's important not to change
things in terms of the way
the components interact with each other,
right?
>> Precisely, this makes sure that you
increase readability, maintain ability
and ease of working with your code but
without breaking the contract that you
have between you and the other
developers you're working with.
>> And the contract that the pieces of
the app have with each other as well.
>> Exactly.
>> Awesome,
that sounds like a good method.
Thank you for sitting with me.
>> Absolutely.